[Music]
October the month of the year which has
the most game releases seriously there
are over 40 games releasing this month
I've grabbed nine of them to show you
today which include two free to play
games so hopefully something for
everyone as always let me know if you'd
like some gameplay or a deeper breakdown
of any of these games so if you're ready
let's do this let's start with Ghost
Recon break points Ubisoft have gone
back to that Tom Clancy well to evolve
the Ghost Recon wildlands game from a
few years ago a tactical military
shooter setting third-person in a huge
sprawling open-world we fill the boots
of Lieutenant Colonel Nomad Perryman a
Special Forces badass sent behind enemy
lines to investigate a series of
disturbances involving some shady tech
companies on the fictional island of
Aurora a quick note that breakpoint will
require an online connection there have
been many petitions to stop this but on
release date at least the internet
connection will be needed to play
speaking of post-launch AI squad mates
are returning if you don't want to go in
alone but dislike real human players
Ubisoft have confirmed squad mates
controlled by AI will have your back
breakpoint will use a new damage system
which affects motion receiving a bullet
to the leg can change your ability to
put weight on that limb thus slowing you
down the way grenades and flashbangs
impact the player also takes this new
system into account drastically
impacting movement visuals and sound
cues so at this point breakpoint feels
like the evolution of wild lance but
here's a massive change weapon stats
levels and tears Ghost Recon is now a
loot driven shooter think of it like a
cut-down version of the division in the
same way assassin's creed became a loop
based RPG Ghost Recon is going down the
same route this could be great or this
could be stressful when your submachine
gun isn't high enough level to damage
the enemies face from one foot away
we'll see on October 4th on ps4 Xbox one
and PC and later in the year for the
stadia to
[Music]
next let's look at shadow keep a paid
expansion for destiny too but get this
destiny is also going free to play with
the new light update releasing on the
very same day October the 1st so how can
the game be free and cost money too so
yeah let's break that down firstly you
know destiny right one of the greatest
feeling first-person shooters ever made
with raids that challenge you and five
other friends and the ever-growing loot
chase around the galaxy the free version
of the game will come with everything
released for destiny - in the first year
on top of that you'll be able to patrol
the new moon destination complete
opening missions in the paid expansion
and of course you'll get the PvP updates
access to year 2 Engram drops and all
the base changes to the game since its
release basically you can play destiny -
casually but Bungie you want to tease
you into paying for the expansion the
real shadow keep experience so what's
behind the paywall of course there's the
full campaign and quest lines attached
to shadow keep a new dungeon and raid
and access to the seasonal events and
rewards kind of like a battle pass in
other games without a doubt the
messaging around destiny - and the
free-to-play model versus the paid model
is the is a mess if I'm honest but at
the core the game is stellar
so if your friends are hardcore destiny
players you'll be able to jump in for
free and see what all the fuss is about
and yes going back to the moon is a big
deal for og players Ares mod has a great
deal time to four-cross dave is here in
destiny - allowing us to jump between
platforms and the new reworked armor
system drops alongside the new content
new light and shadow key released on
October the 1st on ps4 Xbox and PC
[Music]
on October the 9th keep an eye out for
concrete genie which releases on ps4
with psvr extras we play as Ashe a child
who has been bullied but suddenly
discovers he can bring his pictures and
paintings to life as you can already
tell this is something completely
different a game without gun violence
and a game with a touch of unique
fantasy living in a small fishing town
which is polluted and in ruin our job is
to cleanse the streets with art which so
happens to come alive using a ps4
controller and the motion sensor inside
will paint creatures whilst being
pursued by those bullies we mentioned
there are some tense moments to survive
as ash explores his new powers but
ultimately this is a hugely uplifting
experience the addition of psvr gives
players a new way to paint and create
art using the standard controller or the
Move controllers and this is all linked
to a separate quest for this mode where
we help a genie named splosh when we
complete this we will have access to the
free paint mode and create anything we
can imagine
concrete genie releases on October the
9th and is a ps4 exclusive and the
virtual reality stuff is not required
it's an optional extra completely free
call of duty modern warfare returns this
month a first-person shooter
aimed at recapturing the old days of the
cod series modern warfare is a soft
reboot of the franchise putting us back
in the field
with legendary SAS Captain Price more
info on the solo campaign is due out
this week and judging by prices images
this will set up his legacy predating
the previous games if indeed they choose
to link both versions of the game the
multiplayer aspect of modern warfare
feels great ultra responsive and easy to
play no more flying around in an
exoskeleton armored suit no more trying
to be titanfall basically our boots are
back on the ground and Call of Duty gets
back to doing what it's bloody good at
also keep an eye out for the new mode
special ops to be announced soon all we
know at this point is the tagline
intense squad based missions will be
revealed soon it sounds good
if you're on the fence try to jump in on
one of the open betas going on at the
moment to help you make a decision on
October 25th modern warfare returns on
ps4 PC and Xbox one it's the time of
year when the latest WWE offering hits
the shelves WWE 2k 20 continues the
evolution of wrestling video games and
is more cinematic than ever before it
feels like you are watching the real
show whether you're here to beat the
crap out of Roman reigns or maybe you
want to see Becky Lynch rise to the top
of the roster WWE 2k 20 has you covered
every match you can imagine is included
Hell in a Cell yeah TLC of course
ladders matches song vs thong matches
okay I made one of those up but you get
the idea
in terms of update the controls have
been streamlined and the my career mode
has both male and female superstars and
the main showcase of the year is the
women's revolution chronicling the
journey of the four horsewomen I'm quite
into this this year so I'm gonna cut a
promo now all time gaming I see you over
there you setup punks
I challenge you you egg-sucking gutter
trash to a winner-takes-all TLC match
for the title of most mediocre gaming
channel on YouTube I wait for your
response okay don't worry they won't
reply the championship is are already
mine WWE 2k twenty drop kicks into your
life on October the 22nd on ps4 Xbox one
and PC are you a fan of fallout games
were you a little upset by how well
horrible fallout 76 was on release yeah
me too
well there's a franchise you should
consider the outer worlds created by
obsidian entertainment the same people
who created one of the greatest Fallout
games new vegas a first-person
role-playing game with science fiction
at its heart after waking from cryo
sleep we unlock a spaceship which acts
as our fast travel vessel oh and by the
way this game is set in an alternative
reality to our own in which 1901 is the
point of divergence creating a world
which is run by mega corporations and
has ventured into space to colonize and
terraform other planets each planet will
be completely different from technical
marvels to rundown huts and villages
there is tons to explore on everyone you
meet is voiced and a huge number of
those are fully interactive with voice
acting which so far seems to be a high
standard as a fallout fan I'm hyped to
see a real alternative to that series
the outer world releases on October 25th
on ps4 Xbox one and PC and there will be
a switch version coming in the later
days and just in case you're wondering
this is a single-player only campaign
[Music]
another racing game hits this month grit
is back and it's a reboot to the series
racing games are notoriously difficult
to stand apart from one another because
of the vehemence
you know the forces the GranTurismo zuv
the world grid is going down the path of
having multiple routes to the finish
line and get this the Nemesis system in
which one or more of the drivers will
dislike you and act more aggressive when
your vehicle is around this creates a
personalized feeling running through the
entire season grid releases on October
11th on ps4 Xbox one and PC another
retro game making a comeback is Super
Monkey Ball blitz HD if you're new to
this series you play as a monkey stuck
in a rubberized ball destined to find
all his bananas before escaping the
level rinse and repeats 100 times and
you have Super Monkey Ball October 29th
if you're interested on ps4 Xbox one and
switch with the Steam version coming
later in the year other releases this
month include Luigi's Mansion while you
switch mains out there wanting to hunt
down ghosts at Halloween PC gamers you
should consider John wick hex which is a
strategy assassin game sounds
interesting doesn't it and here on
PlayStation the remaster of a classic is
about to drop Mehdi evil it's true the
og action-adventure hack-and-slash Athan
is back 21 years after the original
is there a place for this in modern
gaming or will you admire this from a
distance I personally hope it does
really well because of the nostalgia I
mean who doesn't want to play as a
reanimated corpse who takes on an evil
sorcerer trying to take over the world
October 25th but this one
[Music]
so there we have it 9 games for the
month of October 2019
equip note that Caravan stories the
free-to-play game I told you about a few
months ago is now finally available but
only in North America so sorry if you're
an EU gamer like me Caravan stories is a
Japanese RPG well it's not like an an
MMO cross with a pseudo turn-based RPG I
haven't looked into the microtransaction
so please be wary of that if you choose
to play volley so what the heck are you
grabbing this month I personally can't
wait for Ghost Recon break point but
what about you I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade get in touch with me on Twitter
if I've missed anything
I'm always open for an improvement
thanks for your time I'll see you soon
[Music]